I was kind of more of a preamble for
this belong story short too many things
happened at once and a whole bunch of
stuff that I want to talk about happen
all at the same time including two
trailers now I am I don't have there
aren't enough hours in the day for me to
record my full thoughts edit it and put
it out there in the way that I would
normally like to do with these sorts of
things so what you're going to get
instead are some immediate reactions now
I haven't watched of these trailers yet
first one I'm doing is the new game of
Thrones Season seven teaser I'm not
putting up a little mini video of the
thing i don't i don't want to get my
channel flag so you need to watch it
first before I do this and give my
immediate impressions here we go ominous
that that's fitting man gets an electric
guitar nothing says Game of Thrones like
electric guitar I can t fair identity
dynamis I don't know if everybody uses
that or not I don't know if I'm gonna
ask for asking that
okay so Benares Jon Snow Searcy so we're
looking at reestablishing sort of our
main factions I'm so expecting denerith
and Jon Snow de to team up though
there's no reason for them to be it
everybody taking their respective
Thrones looking badass Oh seriously
break she's gonna wreck shop
[Music]
blinking and candles go out oh okay that
that's not honestly I wasn't thinking
too much of this until it singled out
Searcy and she had just the exhale and
the the cold breath and like yeah she
yep that's that is that is who she is
now I'm sure there are people if they
haven't already who are going to read
into that somehow that she somehow in
cahoots with the White Walkers because
we're going from her icy breath to the
eye of a white Walker and I don't think
that's the case I think they're just
going you know dears the cold-hearted
[ __ ] and here's the much bigger threat
to all three of them regardless but I'm
sure there are some people who are going
to try and draw associations and links
and figure out how she could be goats
with them I don't think that'll be the
case because at least off the top of my
head I can't think of any way that makes
any kind of sense like at all just in
terms of her the hair and what she's
after what the White Walkers wrapped in
the fact that so far as I can tell no
one can actually communicate with the
damn things so yeah I don't see that
happening i'm sure people will read into
it that was fine it was fine i was
functional it was one of those sort of
basic reminders hey it's coming I was
well shot I like that it what it did
well was it narrow the focus for
remember these are the three really
important people right now so I think
that's a nice thing to remind us ahead
of the thing actually getting going I'm
sure we'll get another trailer something
with actual footage from the show I did
like it i like to tease it before that
too which was just the house sigils that
was just you know cool and symbolic and
all that stuff so i know i like it um it
doesn't I was going to say it doesn't
get me pumped that's but that
like I'm not coming for more game of
thrones I'm incredibly bumper more game
of thrones but that doesn't get me any
more pumped than I already was it was
just more of a yeah yeah it's coming
winter is coming even though we won't
freaking go away where I'm supposed to
get sick more inches of snow tomorrow I
can't ah in a hit any case that's it for
Game of Thrones solid work I like it so
have you checked out the game of Thrones
Season seven teaser trailer official
promo thing whatever your thoughts were
on it from something down the comment us
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter and
council of geeks give a listen to the
council and geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]